say you've got to process thousands or
even millions of highly variable
incoming documents every day but your
document capture system requires a pair
of eyes to look over many of the
documents making the review process
costly and very very slow still you need
certainty and the ability to respond to
customers quickly and you can't hire
hundreds of new employees to keep up
instead make your document capture
system cognitive IBM data cap insight
Edition is a cognitive capture solution
that combines advanced imaging rules
natural language processing and machine
learning technologies like those used in
Watson to automatically classify and
extract information in real time from
any document type now you can catalog
and analyze valuable information with
little or no human intervention and you
can deliver relevant information to
users so they can make business
decisions faster and with greater
confidence regardless of document source
type or complexity organizations in
every industry can benefit from
cognitive capture insurance companies
can use IBM data cap insight Edition to
analyze high-value claims and accelerate
processing for health care organizations
it's text analytics capabilities help
identify relevant information in medical
records and financial institutions can
count on its ability to learn bringing
intelligence to processing loans and
customer accounts
that's IBM data cap insight Edition
document capture for the cognitive era
is here